we did a lot of this conversation before
the Hamas attack on Israel and we
decided to sit down again and finish the
discussion to address the current
situation which is still developing if I
may allow me to summarize the situation
as it stands today it's morning Monday
October 9th on Saturday October 7th at
6:30 a.m. Israel time Hamas fired
thousands of rockets into Southern
Israel the rocket attack served as cover
for a multi-pronged infiltration of
Israel territory by over 1,000 Hamas
militants this is shortly after at 7:40
a.m. the Hamas militans went door too in
Border towns killing civilians and
taking captives including women and
children in response to this Israeli Air
Force began carrying out strikes in Gaza
also fighting on the ground in Israel to
clear out Hamas militants from Israel
territory and preparing to mobilize
Israel isi troops for potential ground
attack on Hamas and Gaza now of course
this is what it appears to be right now
and this along with other things might
change because the the situation is
still developing the IDF is ordering
civilian residents of Gaza to evacuate
their homes for their safety Benjamin n
yahu declared war in several statements
and warned Israelis to brace themselves
for a long and difficult War just today
Israeli ministers ordered a quote
Complete Siege of Gaza interrupting
supplies of electricity food water and
fuel from Israel to Gaza as of now
October 9th the death toll is over 12200
people and over 130 hostages taken to
Gaza by
Hamas uh so as I said the events are
rapidly unfolding so these numbers will
sadly increase uh but hopefully our WS
here can at least in part speak to the
the Timeless underlying currence of the
history and uh as you write about the
power dynamics of the region so for
people who don't know Gaza is a 25 mil
long 6 mil wide strip of territory along
the Mediterranean Sea it borders Israel
on the east and north and Egypt on the
Southwest it's densely populated about
2.3 million people and there's been a
blockade of Gaza by Israel and Egypt
since 2007 when Hamas took power I could
just summarize that Hamas is a
Palestinian militant Group which rules
the Gaza Strip it originated in 1988 and
it came to power in Gaza in 2006 as part
of its Charter it sworn to the
destruction of Israel and it is
designated by the United States European
Union UK and of course Israel as a
terrorist group so given that context
what are your feelings as a human being
uh and what is what is your analysis as
the former senior advisor to the
president under the Trump administration
of the current situation in Israel in
Gaza so I think you did an excellent job
of summarizing a lot of the the context
but watching what's unfolded over the
last 48 hours has been truly
heartbreaking to see we're still in the
early stages of what's developing but
seeing the images uh on X of um you know
militants terrorists going door too with
machine guns gunning down innocent
civilians uh seeing beheaded Israeli
soldiers seeing uh young 20-year-olds at
a rave uh uh dance party to celebrate
peace uh with militants flying in and
then you know shooting machine guns to
to kill people
indiscriminately uh seeing uh young
children uh captive and and held
prisoner seeing 80-year-old grandmothers
a holocaust Survivor also being taken
captive uh these are just
images and actions that we have not seen
in this world since 911 this is a terror
attack on the scale of which uh we have
not seen and it's been incredibly hard
for a lot of people to
comprehend um my heart goes out
obviously to uh all of the the families
of the victims uh to the families of
those who are held in captive now and to
all of Israel because one of the
beautiful things about the state of
Israel is that when one Israeli is
hurting the entire nation comes together
uh it's a shame that it's taking an
action like this to unify the nation but
I have seen uh incredibly uh beautiful
signs over the last 48 hours of a
country coming together uh the Jewish
people have been under oppression before
uh the Jewish people know what it's like
and seeing people rally together to uh
fight for their Homeland to to to try to
reestablish safety uh is is um is a very
beautiful thing to watch I wish it
wasn't something we had to watch but it
is uh with that being said though the
backdrop I've been speaking to friends
over the last couple days I have one
friend I spoke with um last night who
was saying that uh you know a good
friend messaged him saying I'm going in
we're going to do some operations to try
to free some of the hostages held in one
of the kutes messaged him the next
morning morning he was one of the first
through the door to try to free these
hostages and he was killed by a Hamas
militant and sadly we're going to be
hearing many many more stories of Brave
Israeli soldiers trying to uh get these
terrorists out of Israel trying to free
innocent civilians who unfortunately are
risking their lives uh to do it and um
you know they're all heroes but some
will have less good fith than others uh
sadly so it's a very very
heartbreaking moment um and I do think
that it's very important at this moment
in time for the entire world to stand
behind Israel I think that Hamas has
shown uh the entire world who they
really are I think what their aim is
what they're willing to do um and you
know all of the uh strong security that
Israel's put in place over the last
years which in some instances was
criticized I think is now being
validated that um that there was a real
threat that they were looking to deter
so um short answer is my heart is broken
uh praying for peace praying for
strength praying for um praying for
Israel to do what it needs to do to
avoid being in this situation again
which is either eliminating or severely
degrading hamas's capabilities uh there
there cannot be peace in Israel and in
the Middle East while there's a terror
group um that is being funded by Iran
that is allowed to uh flourish and is
allowed to plan operations that are
going to aim to kill innocent civilians
and so as somebody who was formerly in
this position who uh was intimately
involved with Israel with uh the
strategies to to minimize uh attacks
from Hamas and to try to uh turn the
region around and I think we did do a
very substantial job under President
Trump the Middle East went from one of
the most chaotic regions in the world
you had uh Isis uh 2016 Isis had a
califate the size of Ohio they were
beheading journalists they were um they
were they were killing Christians um
they controlled 8 million people they
were planning attacks um uh all over the
world from their their caliphate they
were uh using the internet to radicalize
people we had the San Bernardino
shooting in America we had the PSE
nightclub shooting uh in in in
Orlando and there was real threat and
then you had Iran which was given $150
billion in a Glide path to a nuclear
weapon and they were using their
Newfound riches to fund Hamas Hezbollah
the houthis uh different Rebels uh all
over the the region that were looking to
destabilize further Syria was in a civil
war where 500,000 people were killed
Yemen was destabilized syri Libya was
destabilized and it was just a mess and
all of America's allies had felt
betrayed president Trump came into power
we rebuilt the the trust and the
relationships with all of our
traditional allies and we were able to
eliminate Isis the Cal territorial
caliphate and then we were able to
project strength in the region really go
after Iran's uh wallet uh we were able
to stop uh through through crushing
sanctions a lot of their financial uh
resources which they were using to fund
all these Terror groups and so we left
the Middle East uh with six piece deals
and in a fairly uh peaceful world so
seeing what's happening I think it was
completely avoidable I think it's
horrible to see that it's occurring uh
and I pray that those in power will make
the right decisions to uh to to to
restore safety but also to potentially
create uh a better Paradigm uh for peace
in the
future